[Music]  after the west side of Chicago we used  to walk up and down the street saying my  name on this building is insane damn  right you should clap for that  let's go  I love being my little grown-ass  relationship I'm trying to be with no  young [ __ ] that's too much  energy one of my homeboys this girl like  25 every time I see him he's tired we  went on a double date she's like yeah we  went to karaoke on Monday Tuesday we did  this we went to Tulum on Wednesday  that [ __ ] just sitting there like this  left the job went to Tulum right after  work went to the airport right after  work  these passes are losing their [ __ ]  mind watching the old [ __ ] that's  talking about Beyonce she worships the  devil that's what he said he said she's  got all that goddamn money that is the  results  you dumb [ __ ] you just promoted  the devil  [Applause]  [Music]